[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
question d'actualité sur LCP très
heureuse de vous retrouver ici en direct
de la salle des pas perdus à quelques
mètres de la salle des quatre colonnes
et de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale où vous allez pouvoir suivre à
partir de 15 heures la séance de
questions au Gouvernement une séance
retransmise en direct et en intégralité
sur LCP alors au lendemain de l'échec de
la motion de censure déposée par la Nupe
l'Assemblée nationale tente de tourner
la page des retraites même si les plaies
sont encore bien ouvertes dans les
oppositions la majorité elle se tourne
vers l'après et les prochains textes
avec plusieurs inconnus quelle majorité
pour voter les futurs projets de loi le
groupe Renaissance peut-il se diviser à
l'occasion d'un texte sur l'immigration
et puis surtout quel gouvernement pour
porter ses réformes on va tenter de
répondre à ces questions et de traiter
toute l'actualité parlementaire avec
Elsa mon ningava et Marco pommier qui se
trouve salle des quatre colonnes avec
Clément mairie qui est lui aussi dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
pour le menu au gouvernement et puis
nous vous ferons vivre à partir de 14h45
l'arrivée de la première ministre et des
membres du gouvernement ce sera cours
d'honneur c'est l'entrée principale du
palais Bourbon alors Marco Polo on va
vous retrouver vous celle des quatre
colonnes alors au lendemain de l'échec
de la motion de censure de la nuque quel
est l'ambiance de votre côté ben écoutez
brigitte c'est plutôt calme ici ça le
des quatre colonnes même si ce matin en
conférence de presse les différents
groupes politiques avaient bien en tête
encore cette motion de censure d'hier
qui n'a pas été adoptée vous l'avez dit
il a manqué 50 voix pour pour renverser
le gouvernement d'Élisabeth borne alors
ce gouvernement il reste en place pour
l'instant et pour combien de temps
surtout car ce matin salle des quatre
salles des quatre colonnes on parlait
beaucoup aussi des rumeurs de
remaniement un éventuel remaniement qui
pourrait intervenir avant le 14 juillet
merci Marco on va retrouver Clément
Méric dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes déjà dans les
tribunes Clément pas de Question
Retraite cette semaine Clément
et non brigitte c'est la triste attaque
au couteau d'Annecy qui devrait
concentrer le plus de questions au
gouvernement lors de cette séance à
partir de 15 heures avec pas moins de 3
questions qui seront toutes posées par
des députés du département de
Haute-Savoie des députés membres de la
majorité des questions qui porteront à
la fois sur le déroulé de cette attaque
mais aussi sur les modalités
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre et
des secours également également que le
profil de l'auteur de cette attaque vous
savez un réfugié syrien dont la demande
d'asile avait été rejetée quelques jours
plus tôt par la France et bien le profil
de l'auteur de cette attaque devrait
être évoqué par le député RN Yoann
Gillet dans la question qu'il posera
question consacrée au projet de loi
immigration
merci Clément mairie et je vous présente
à présent mes invités pour cette
première partie de questions d'actualité
Jean René Cazeneuve bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes rapporteur général
du budget et député renaissance du Gers
et puis avec nous aussi Valérie Rabault
bonjour vous êtes vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et vous êtes
député socialiste du Tarn-et-Garonne
ancienne rapporteur général du budget
c'était sous François Hollande alors je
vous le disais en titre la motion de
censure déposée par la Nupe a échoué
hier à 50 voix près toutes les
oppositions ont usées et bien tous les
recours possibles ici à l'Assemblée
nationale alors pour la Présidence de
l'Assemblée Yaël Braun Pivet interrogé
par nos confrères de RTL ce matin et
bien c'est la fin de l'histoire écoutez
là
séquence est à présent aujourd'hui
terminé l'assemblée peut se remettre au
travail ce qu'elle n'a pas manqué de
faire immédiatement après le vote de la
motion
alors c'est vous effectivement qui
portiez Valérie rabot cette motion de
censure de la nuque elle n'a pas été
adoptée est-ce que comme le dit à elbron
Pivet la séquence est aujourd'hui
terminé il faut passer à autre chose
alors il y a plusieurs choses sur cette
notion de censure sur les retraites il
est vrai que nous avons épuisé les
recours qui pouvaient exister ça veut
pas dire que le combat que nous portons
s'arrête c'est-à-dire que nous ferons
continuerons à formuler des propositions
il y aura d'autres élections plus tard
donc dans quelques années donc nous
continuerons à travailler sur cette
question là mais il est ça veut dire
dans une prochaine niche du Parti
socialiste il pourrait y avoir un texte
sur les retraites
tout de suite donc moi je veux pas
donner de faux espoirs à celles et ceux
qui qui nous écoutent il y aura
évidemment nous ne lâchons pas l'affaire
sur les 64 ans pour autant je vais quand
même reconnaître devant vous que à ce
stade il n'y a pas de perspective à
court terme sur la question
des retraites mais la motion que j'ai
défendu hier c'est dans le fond sur le
discrédit que jette le gouvernement sur
l'Assemblée nationale et ça je peux pas
l'accepter ce qui s'est passé jeudi
dernier
maintenant la la façon de recevoir les
textes de traiter les textes ici à
l'Assemblée nationale
précédent si vous me permettez je n'ai
pas ma vie que la président travaux
c'est la vie qui a été donnée par le
président Coquerel de la commission des
finances sur l'article et qui de tout
évident et personne ne vous dit le
contraire il y a pas un prof de droit il
y a pas un constitutionnalisme qui vous
dit le contraire l'article 1 n'était pas
recevable donc en aucune manière quand
il a été saisi il aurait dû accepter et
ça c'est impressionnant avec les
conséquences qu'on a vu moi je peux mais
pas d'accord surtout mais on peut se
dire qu'effectivement notre institution
au sort abîmée de cette de cette
séquence on savait depuis le début que
cette loi n'avait de toute façon aucune
chance d'aller au bout je regrette que
certains allaient agiter pour créer des
espérances qui n'avaient pas de chance
de réussir donc oui il y a un travail
qu'il faut faire maintenant pour
réexpliquer le le sens de notre
Constitution cet article 40 en deux mots
il sert à quoi il sert à protéger nos
finances publiques tout simplement à
éviter que les uns et les autres
puissent y c'est que le aujourd'hui les
initiatives venant de l'opposition par
exemple n'auront plus lieu d'être parce
que quasiment toutes les propositions de
loi son coûteuses pour les finances
publiques il y en a plus de la moitié
qui ne sont pas coûteuses il faut que
quelqu'un saisisse au titre de l'article
40 pour savoir si un texte créé une
charge ou pas on peut se mettre d'accord
comme on l'a fait depuis le dernier
mandat sur un certain nombre
d'initiatives qu'elles viennent de
l'opposition ou de la majorité on peut
aussi faire pression sur le gouvernement
pour qu'il lève le gage c'est de son
autorité de manière à ce que les PPL a
jusqu'au bout c'est ce qu'on a déjà fait
alors Valérie rabot vous êtes anciennes
rapporteur général du budget est-ce que
pour vous cet article 40 il leur est dû
être utilisé sur cette proposition de
loi liotte ou pas est-ce que elle est
recevable ou pas cette provision loi
plusieurs en toute honnête non mais en
toute honnêteté je vais vous répondre en
toute honnêteté moi aussi je suis
soucieuse des finances publiques et je
pense qu'il y a un garde-fou pour
empêcher que les finances publiques
partent dans le décor je suis d'accord
mais ce que j'observe c'est que depuis
19 48 ce garde-fou existe et il a été
utilisé d'une façon intelligente c'est
de dire les amendements il s'appliquent
sur les propositions de loi quand elles
sont recevables il y a une certaine
souplesse et je voudrais rappeler à Jean
René Cazeneuve que depuis 2012 il y a eu
60 propositions de loi sur les retraites
qui augmentaient les charges jugées
recevables juger recevable par le Bureau
de l'Assemblée nationale et donc
aujourd'hui on crée un précédent on crée
un précédent qui est dangereux parce que
qui décide ça veut dire que c'est la loi
de l'arbitraire et bien vous savez
l'arbitraire il existe dans les
dictatures et moi je ne souhaite pas
qu'il existe à l'Assemblée nationale
donc depuis 1958 à chaque fois vous
aviez un amendement vous diriez que
c'est une dérive libérales je dirais que
ce qui s'est passé jeudi dernier est une
très grave c'est très dangereux et je ne
sais pas quelles peuvent être les
conséquences pour l'Assemblée nationale
jusqu'à présent lorsqu'une proposition
loi est déclarée recevable c'est-à-dire
quand elle est sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale si un amendement
de rétablissement pour la rétablir il
est jugé recevable ça c'est tout le
temps passé tout le temps tout le temps
sans exception
sans exception depuis 1958 et Jean-René
Cazeneuve je vais le titiller un peu sur
les 60 propositions de loi qui ont eu
lieu sur pour établir les retraites
enfin pour changer les retraites baisser
l'âge légal etc depuis 2012 la dernière
qui a été votée c'était pour dire on
prend en compte les 25 meilleures années
donc ça coûte de l'argent vous étiez
déjà rapporteur général du budget en
plus vous l'avez voté vous n'êtes pas
intervenu dans l'hémicycle pour dire oh
là oh là moi j'interviens aussi de
l'article 89-4 pour dire que c'est pas
ressort de deux anciens un anciennes
ancien rapporteur un actuel rapporteur
général du budget qui ne pense pas la
même chose finalement ça veut dire que
dans l'un des cas il y a une décision
politique une décision partisane
quand on n'est pas d'accord et c'est le
principe de notre démocratie il faut
revenir au texte et il faut revenir à la
Constitution et moi je prends pas la
Constitution à la carte je prends pas
les articles qui m'intéressent et je
supprime ce qui m'intéresse pas pourquoi
sur la loi je vous ai écouté je vais
vous répondre sur la loi vous avez pris
vous voyez c'est que il y avait
il y avait un consensus seul le
gouvernement peut lever le gage ce qui
est important est-ce que Valérie bon
fait semblant de ne pas comprendre
c'est la réalité c'est la réalité parce
que c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable des grands équilibres
budgétaires bien évidemment ne faites
pas semblant de le de le découvrir ce
que je veux dire ce qui est quand même
plus grave c'est quand même plus grave
que ce que dit la prison très beau et
moi je le regrette si vous voulez parle
de dictature oui c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui elle n'es pas non vous avez
parlé de dictature elle
n'hésite pas et n'hésite pas si vous
voulez à s'associer dans la dialectique
à une extrême gauche aujourd'hui qui
cogne sur nos institutions qui ne rêvent
que d'une chose c'est de mettre à mal
aux institutions pour la remplacer par
je ne sais quoi par une sixième
république donc caisson j'avais posé
derrière un mot est-ce qu'elle est pour
la Sixième République et qu'elle nous
dit votre réponse et puis je vais
répondre très clairement je suis pour
qu'on respecte les usages de l'Assemblée
nationale depuis 1958 les
les amendements de rétablissement ont
été jugés recevables sans aucune
exception depuis 1958 la seule exception
c'est celle qui s'est passée jeudi 8
juin dernier de votre fée et donc c'est
je considère une exception qui est une
entaille j'espère pas très profonde dans
le fonctionnement démocratique de
l'Assemblée nationale et oui je suis
pour le respect des institutions et non
je ne suis pas pour mettre à mal les
institutions mais oui parce que je suis
pour le respect des institutions la
règle depuis 1958 aurait dû continuer à
être appliqué comme elle l'a toujours
été ce qui s'est passé jeudi dernier est
une entorse à cette règle pour vous
mettre à pas d'accord c'est sûr sur sur
ce plateau
c'est vraiment là le péché originaire
des quatre colonnes Elsa on l'a dit il
n'y a plus de recours plus d'initiative
parlementaire possible contre la réforme
des retraites alors sur quoi va
désormais se pencher l'assemblée et bien
écoutez les députés ont commencé des
hier soir l'examen d'une proposition de
loi sur l'accès aux soins avec
qui ne débat sur la liberté
d'installation des médecins au programme
également avant la pause estivale à un
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
côté affaires sociales deux textes une
proposition de loi sur le partage de la
valeur c'est en fait la transposition de
l'accord signé entre les partenaires
sociaux la quasi-totalité des
partenaires sociaux et puis le projet de
loi France travail avec une mesure qui
fait débat les nouvelles obligations
pour les allocataires du RSA pour la
dernière semaine de session celle tout
de suite après le 14 juillet les députés
plancheront sur le projet de loi
industrie verte réindustrialisée le pays
mais avec une industrie décarbonée alors
Elsa il y a aussi un grand texte qui est
attendu sur l'immigration mais là le
calendrier n'est pas encore calé oui
attendu plutôt à l'automne peut-être
sera-t-il présenté en juillet on le sait
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin cherche à obtenir une majorité
sur un texte une majorité pourquoi pas
avec les républicains qui eux sont prêts
à voter et bien leur propre proposition
à leur entre les lignes rouges de la
droite et celle de la majorité
l'équilibre semble très compliqué à
trouver pour le gouvernement et puis à
l'automne il y a évidemment comme chaque
année à l'Assemblée le marathon
budgétaire merci Elsa muningava Valérie
rabot est-ce qu'on peut reprendre le fil
du quinquennat est-ce que vous vous
dites je peux voter des textes présentés
par le gouvernement avec la majorité si
toutefois ça va dans le bon sens mais
j'en ai déjà voté ça vous aura pas
échappé que nous en avons et un après
retraite vous êtes dans le même état
d'esprit
je pense quand même que les retraites
ont constitué une cassure une cassure
démocratique une question dans le pays
parce que franchement je sais pas
comment c'est pour genre on est
Cazeneuve dans le Gers mais moi il y a
quand même des beaucoup de mes
concitoyens qui m'a des concitoyens de
ma circonscription qui m'interpellent en
disant mais c'est incroyable vous n'avez
pas pu voter sur la réforme retraite
donc je ne sais pas comment les choses
vont s'enclencher je ne sais pas quel
est l'état d'esprit du gouvernement nous
nous avons toujours été constructifs
nous avons voté on n'aura pas de
conséquences
sur les énergies renouvela passent donc
on a pas de problème quand on est
d'accord quand on obtient des
discussions à voter mais
voilà le ce qui s'est passé jeudi
dernier avec une entaille profonde dans
le fonctionnement de l'Assemblée
nationale genre René Cazeneuve est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à attendre la main à
la gauche comme à la droite sur les
prochains textes à dialoguer peut-être
un peu plus est-ce que vous aussi vous
tirez peut-être quelques quelques
conclusions quelques conséquences
finalement de ce qui s'est passé sous
cette réforme des retraites
un manque de dialogue on vous a
peut-être reproché non je pense que le
manque de dialogue si vous voulez s'il y
a un sujet dont on parle depuis des
années des années sur lequel des
concertations extrêmement c'est bien le
sujet des retraites si vous voulez ça
dure depuis depuis très longtemps non on
va je crois
moi aussi je sors
triste de cette séquence n'aurait pas
même quelqu'un de très rationnel on
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord sur
l'interprétation de ce qui s'est passé
comprenez notre position qui est de
respecter la Constitution rien que la
Constitution non mais il faut je crois
comme on essaye de le faire depuis le
début et d'essayer de trouver des
majorités textes par textes on n'a pas
d'autre solution les Français nous ont
mis dans cette position de majorité
relative donc on l'a fait sans exception
sauf pour les retraites et les textes
budgétaires et bien il faut continuer
sur sur cette méthode moi ce que me
disent les Français dans ma circo que
rrbo connait bien ils me disent mais
comment vous pouvez travailler avec des
socialistes qui quand ils étaient au
pouvoir sont parvenus sur le retraites à
62 ans et qui aujourd'hui se battent
pour une retraite à 60 ans il ne
comprennent pas comment les socialistes
qui sont dans une relation très tendue
qui n'ont pas de mots assez durs avec la
France insoumise peuvent aujourd'hui
s'allier avec eux à l'Assemblée
nationale sur des textes qui n'ont pas
des liens c'est ça qu'on me dit donc je
pense que effectivement notre démocratie
a pris des coups pendant cette séquence
là il faut écouter expliquer et moi je
suis évidemment prêt à travailler je
commence à recevoir la responsable de
toutes les oppositions pour préparer le
budget on est évidemment prêts et ouvert
sur le dialogue alors il y aura il y a
eu déjà 17 notions de censure pour une
seule année puisque c'était il y a un an
le premier tour des élections
législatives c'est un record évidemment
on s'attend sur le budget justement à de
nouveau 49-3 puisqu'on sait que c'est un
vote qui est quand même assez politique
et certainement deux nouvelles motions
de censure Valérie rabot vous qui avez
l'expérience ici du Parlement est-ce
qu'on peut continuer quatre ans comme ça
et depuis le départ on que la Cinquième
République dans le fond était un régime
qui nécessite d'avoir une majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale donc il
y a pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale il manque 41 41
voix je crois bon donc c'est beaucoup
mais ça là-dessus le celui qui a la
première ou celle qui a la première la
responsabilité d'essayer de trouver un
mode de fonctionnement c'est le groupe
principal demandez pas aux oppositions
de définir le mode de fonctionnement
c'est le groupe principal qui doit
formuler un certain nombre soit de
propositions soit être capable d'amender
beaucoup plus les textes donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet je vous dis nous par
exemple quand on a voté les énergies
renouvelables les énergies vertes il
vous aura pas échappé que c'est les
votes socialistes qui ont permis que le
texte soit voté donc c'est des compromis
nous sommes capables d'en faire là nous
avons une situation enfin en tout cas
qui est très compliqué et je pense
qu'elle est aussi compliqué dans la
majorité parce que les trois derniers
votes qui concernent le rapporteur
général sur les deux la loi de règlement
2021 pour lequel vous avez demandé un
second vote par rapport à celui de l'an
dernier qui est à nouveau été rejeté la
loi de règlement 2022 la loi de
règlement de la sécurité sociale rejetée
ça dit peut-être plus quelque chose de
l'absence de mobilisation du groupe
majoritaire que des oppositions en tout
cas ça a été rejeté on dit souvent que
la rentrée ça sera chaude elle sera
brûlante au Parlement je renais
Cazeneuve vous aurez en plus le budget à
défendre très rapidement
on a besoin d'une république
encore plus compliqué son budget
d'autant plus qu'on a des contraintes et
que vous savez qu'il y a pas grand monde
pour partager la responsabilité sur les
contraintes il y aura beaucoup de monde
pour proposer des dépenses
supplémentaires il y aura très très peu
de monde pour proposer des économies
donc non non écoutez je suis très ouvert
ce vote sur les lois de réglementation
ça c'est symptomatique si vous voulez
nous sommes
minoritaires nous n'avons pas la
majorité absolue donc effectivement
quand toutes les oppositions vote contre
nous les textes passeports
là
on est mécaniquement mat pratiquement on
n'a pas la majorité absolue et c'est un
fait donc effectivement quand les
oppositions moi ce que je regrette aussi
si vous voulez c'est que quand on est
battu oui il s'applaudit il se lève ils
sont contents il y a une grande victoire
bon là sur les textes de règlement c'est
juste un problème pour les
fonctionnaires qui s'occupent des
comptes mais c'est simplement que
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite on
voter ensemble je pense pas que ce soit
un gain pour notre démocratie alors on
va avancer et on va parler d'un autre
texte à
présenter le sujet des déserts médicaux
quand même ah ben on va d'aborder
justement voilà vous allez démarcher
innovante qui a lancé Guillaume Garraud
oui oui dernier et mais on va en parler
justement puisque cette autre texte dont
je voulais vous parler c'est cette
proposition de loi du groupe horizon qui
est porté par Frédéric valthou et qui
vise à lutter contre les déserts
médicaux Frédéric waltou qui est
justement à vos côtés Marco pommier
député horizon de Seine-et-Marne alors
est-ce que ça proposition de loi
pourrait créer des contraintes
d'installation pour les médecins
et bien écoutez c'est ce qu'on va voir
Brigitte Frédéric valtrous ce soir les
regards seront tournés vers un
amendement proposé par un groupe de
travail transpartisans groupe de travail
transpartisans portés par Guillaume
Garraud cette amendement il veut mettre
en place la régulation de l'installation
des médecins en fonction des besoins des
territoires Vous vous opposez à cette
régulation pourquoi la régulation à
l'installation pour moi aujourd'hui
n'est pas adapté à la crise que
connaître notre système de santé pour
une raison toute simple le principal
motif de cette crise principale cause de
cette crise c'est le manque de soignants
on est face à un mur et on sait que dans
les 5 à 10 prochaines années on aura
moins de soignants qui vont entrer dans
la carrière moi de jeunes soignants qui
vont s'installer jeunes médecin que de
médecins qui vont lâcher parce que ils
sont arrivés à un âge de la retraite et
parfois pour certains bien au-delà de la
retraite et donc on est face à un
phénomène de pénurie qui fait que la
régulation c'est comme un peu agité un
chiffon rouge sous le nez des médecins
il y a d'autres solutions c'est ce qu'on
porte dans nos textes pour arriver à
résoudre cette question de l'accès aux
soins sans passer par effectivement la
régulation qui n'apportera rien à moyen
court terme aux Français ça n'améliorera
pas la situation d'aucun territoire et
pourtant Frédéric Valletoux dans votre
proposition de loi qui est débattue
depuis hier dans l'assemblée cette
proposition de loi elle a été
retravaillée dans sa première version
vous souhaitiez mettre en place un mode
d'autorisation d'installation des
médecins à travers les agences
régionales de santé pourquoi vous y avez
renoncé alors faut se rappeler que cette
proposition loi elle comportait que
quatre articles aujourd'hui on est sur
un objet qui est plus vaste et qui met
des des solutions
sur la table en matière d'accès aux
soins qui sont pour moi plus efficaces
et plus immédiatement efficace que de
réfléchir à la régulation moi le système
de la régulation à l'installation je
suis pas philosophiquement opposé à cela
mais on régulera le jour on aura des
choses à réguler on organisera
différemment le jour où on aura formé
suffisamment de médecins pour organiser
effectivement leur juste installation
dans les territoires mais ça c'est dans
10 ans donc il va falloir travailler
avec la profession travailler avec les
syndicats de médecins pour imaginer un
système voiture aujourd'hui on a dans la
proposition loi des outils plus concrets
la permanence des soins le soir le
week-end les jours fériés comment on
organise mieux la permanence des soins
et pas que sur l'hôpital ou pardon pas
que principalement sur l'hôpital puisque
les libéraux en font mais aujourd'hui on
va mettre en place une permanencement
avec les cliniques et les spécialistes
des cliniques ça c'est nouveau on
continue à lutter contre l'intérim enfin
voilà on a des outils qui permettent
effectivement de fléchir vers les
territoires
les forces médicales de mieux faire
travailler ensemble les forces médicales
et puis surtout de répondre à cette
question lancinante de l'accès aux soins
merci Frédéric Valletoux et rappelons ce
chiffre impressionnant en 87% du
territoire français est un désert
médical merci beaucoup merci Valérie
Rimbault vouliez nous parler justement
de cette amendement transpartisant mais
porté par le député socialiste Guillaume
Garraud qui vise à contraindre les
médecins à s'installer dans des zones
qui sont sous dotées je voulais répondre
à votre question
alors qu'on en manque alors est-ce que
le remettre va pas tuer le malade vous
me dites tout à l'heure est-ce que on va
arriver à travailler ensemble moi
j'observe que Guillaume Garraud a lancé
en juillet dernier quand nous sommes
arrivés un groupe de travail
transpartisan je pense qu'il y avait
aussi quelques députés de la majorité il
y avait des LR il y avait des
socialistes enfin il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de monde et que ce groupe a
abouti à signer un amendement avec 200
députés
26577 il faut quand même l'entendre
c'est c'est pas une majorité
je suis d'accord avec vous et ce groupe
a auditionné pendant 9 mois à la fois
des usagers des représentants des
médecins et ils sont ils ont ils sont
arrivés à un amendement qui est
équilibré dans le fond puisqu'il te dit
l'ARS peut permettre l'installation y
compris dans des zones qui sont pas
classées par elles par les ARS comme
sous doté c'est à dire que on ferme pas
la porte au fait qu'il y aurait plus eu
de nouveaux médecins installés dans des
zones dans les zones il y a suffisamment
de médecins il faudra attendre qu'un
médecin partent à la retraite ou des
ménages pour pouvoir s'installer oui
mais donc c'est vrai qu'une autorisation
quand même donc ils ont repris
exactement le système des pharmaciens
voilà donc ça va pas créer de pénurie de
médecins le la deuxième question c'est
la question du nombre de médecins formés
il en faudrait 15000 par an moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec la solution
qui est du gouvernement qui était dit en
supprime le numérique en 2018 mais c'est
pas parce que vous dites on empêche pas
on supprime le numéro exclusion que vous
créez des postes de formation de
médecins et on est toujours à 10000
médecins à peu près formés par an alors
qu'il en faudrait 15000 tout simplement
parce que les universités qui ont une
forme d'autonomie n'ouvrent pas plus de
poste ben ça dans le prochain budget
j'espère que le rapporteur général
l'inscrira le fait qu'on ouvre beaucoup
plus de postes de formation médecin il
faut arriver à 15000 médecins formés par
an on est à un peu plus de 10000 ce qui
est très insuffisant genre René
Cazeneuve on a vu que les incitations de
fonctionnaient pas aujourd'hui pour que
les médecins s'installent dans dans des
zones creuses j'allais dire des zones
blanches finalement est-ce qu'il faut
pas passer un peu plus de contrainte sa
citation marche quand même initiative de
conseiller départementaux par exemple
qui un certain nombre de médecins et ça
marche sur un certain nombre de
territoires
qui sont en désert médicaux
on a un problème de nombre de médecins
au global si vous voulez donc oui tirer
la couverture la couette dans un sens ou
dans un ou dans un autre si vous voulez
ça sera pas plus grande pour autant bon
donc et 87 % du territoire est un désert
américain si vous voyez on a un problème
majeur donc il faut augmenter le nombre
de médecins c'est ce qu'on a commencé à
faire je crois qu'à 3000 de plus qui
sont formés chaque année mes
probablement il faut aller encore plus
loin des formations comme le dit former
davantage
d'initiatives avec les assistants
médicaux avec la revalorisation du
contenu du métier des pharmaciens des
infirmières et des infirmières des kinés
etc pour que eux-mêmes puissent
décharger d'un certain nombre d'actes
les médecins donc là on gagne du temps
médecin et puis il faut continuer dans
la citation on a ouvert une quatrième
année d'internat qui va être payé très
correctement avec
Si les médecins c'est pour cette
quatrième année d'aller sur des
territoires ruraux et des territoires
qui sont sous dotés voilà on est
vraiment dans l'incitation pour éviter
un retour de bâton et que les médecins
parce que évidemment les médecins ne
sont pas d'accord avec certains moments
et je pense que on aura je trouve c'est
très intéressant moi de vous et prévoit
déjà une grève illimitée à partir du
mois d'octobre
de profession on aura un beau débat et
je pense que j'espère que on aura un
débat apaisé sur cette question qui
intéresse tous les Français c'est leur
prêt que préoccupations numéro 1
aujourd'hui et nous leur devons
évidemment une couverture de santé
satisfaisante à chacun ou qu'il soit sur
le territoire il faut trouver la bonne
solution il y a des choses dans cette
proposition de loi pour vous ça résoudra
pas le problème des déserts médicaux
déjà moi je ne comprends pas que depuis
2018 nous sommes en 2023 on n'est pas
augmenté le nombre de formations parce
qu'il y a plus de numériques
regardez les chiffres on est à peine un
peu plus de 10000 alors il en faudrait
15000 donc ça c'est c'est vraiment je ne
comprends pas qu'en 5 ans parce que là
déjà on aurait sacrément apporté des
solutions nouvelles moi je suis en
Tarn-et-Garonne je ne connais pas la
situation du Gers mais il y a quasiment
10% des habitants de mon département qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant c'est
énorme 10% je sais pas si on se rend
compte de ce que ça signifie de
l'angoisse et vous n'êtes pas une
exception je pense mais non qui est de
l'angoisse que ça crée pour les
habitants surtout quand on habite très
lieu très loin d'un hôpital ou d'un donc
ça c'est vraiment une réalité qui doit
être une priorité et moi j'espère
vraiment que sur le budget qui va être
travaillé à l'automne 2023 on met le
paquet pour ouvrir elle est peut-être
pas 15000 d'un coup mais au moins 13000
et que ce soit fait que ce soit concret
qui est des moyens qui soient donnés aux
universités pour que ces formations
puissent être faites que peut-être il
faille élargir avec peut-être pas que
les CHU mais enfin qui puissent vraiment
y avoir une ouverture là-dessus parce
que sinon dans 5 ans on aura encore la
même discussion 10% des habitants du
Tarn-et-Garonne qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant est-ce que la situation dans le
Gers c'est aussi catastrophique Jean
René
ce déficit donc non non mais ça et que
vous disent les Français sur les
terrains parce que les Français
quand on les interroge l'opinion
publique est plutôt du côté de la
contrainte quand même des médecins en
disant on a besoin de médecins il faut
qu'il s'installe près de chez nous même
si on n'est pas très attractif comme
territoire
nous nous sommes pour l'incitation on
préfère des médecins motivés qui
viennent de même pour de bonnes raisons
premier qu'un médecin qui vient d'en
gère il est très heureux je préfère
qu'il vienne ou de bonnes raisons plutôt
que contrat que à Strasbourg soit
débarqué dans le Gers c'est qu'il est
qu'une envie c'est de repartir je pense
que ce serait pas bon et ça va créer de
la santé je pense qu'il faut aussi créer
de l'envie chez les jeunes vous voyez en
Tarn-et-Garonne sur la deuxième année de
médecine on en a quatre jeunes
Tarn-et-Garonne à Toulouse en étude de
médecine donc c'est très insuffisant
parce que un jeune qui a toujours vécu à
Toulouse dans une grande ville il aura
sans doute peut-être plus de moins
d'envie d'aller s'installer à la
campagne et donc il faut donner aux
jeunes de nos campagnes l'envie de
devenir médecin l'envie de faire passer
scientifique des communautés
professionnelles
pluridisciplinaire
ça passe par aller dans les lycées
montrer que c'est aussi pour eux ces
métiers là sont aussi pour eux parce
qu'effectivement quand vous n'avez que
quatre jeunes tarn-nigarreau qui sont en
deuxième année de médecine à Toulouse
bah s'il y en a deux qui reviennent
c'est très insuffisant pour assurer
la médecine dont on a besoin alors on
l'a dit 200 députés qui ont signé mais
peut-être plus qui vont voter cet
amendement il pourrait être débattu dès
ce soir Jean-René Cazeneuve François
Braun le ministre de la Santé est très
opposé à cette à cet amendement que ce
serait un gros revers politique pour
vous de voir subir une perte sur cet
amendement
politique mais
nous on venait vraiment du côté de
l'incitation donc on a créé cette
quatrième année pour les internats avec
une incitation à venir sur les
territoires où on manque de médecin on
multiplie les initiatives pour faire en
sorte que métier soit plus attractif aux
multiplier les utilisatif ok plus de ton
médecin moi j'ai rencontré des médecins
il y a pas longtemps à Lombez ce qui me
le disait c'est un assistant médical
l'aurait permis de gagner 10% de temps
de médecine supplémentaire donc 10% de
rendez-vous supplémentaires donc je
crois que les solutions court terme
c'est plutôt cela parce qu'autrement on
n'a pas plus de médecins donc on est
contraint il faut augmenter le nombre de
médecins je rejoins la présidente rabot
et on est contraintes de capacité
diversité il faut aussi qu'on fasse
attention c'est quand même sa demande un
niveau d'études importants donc on peut
pas non plus ouvrir les robinets comme
ça donc il faut garder la qualité
formidable de nos de nos formations
médicales donc ce qu'il faut former de
plus en plus de médecins les inciter à
aller dans les territoires ruraux il
faut faire confiance aussi aux acteurs
locales
la PPL Valton elle elle se base là
dessus c'est comment faire décider la
communauté des médecins conseils
territoriaux de médecine de santé
également qui doivent prendre ses
décisions pour répartir pour faire
travailler ensemble les médecins
libéraux et les hôpitaux vers travailler
les différentes familles du monde de la
santé voilà c'est cet enjeu de confiance
de comporte la comporte la confiance et
on verra ce qui se passera sur cette
table bon espoir pour votre amendement
en tout cas celui que très peu
d'amendements par 200 députés dans dans
l'histoire à l'Assemblée nationale donc
on verra on peut jamais prédire ce que
sera un vote mais c'est quand même un
signal très fort on verra déjà c'est les
troupes sont mobilisés c'est un groupe
de juillet dernier transpartisans venez
qui veut c'est une belle initiative de
député et garons et d'ailleurs dans sa
proposition là il y a pas que ça mais il
y a d'autres éléments qu'on que que nous
on trouve très positif et que je avec
plaisir si son texte arrive dans
l'hémicycle cette contrainte non c'est
un peu la ligne rouge mais on verra donc
ce soir alors à suivre peut-être ce soir
en tout cas cet amendement qui pourrait
être soumis au vote des députés merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté de venir
des battes sur le plateau de question
d'actualité on passe à présent au focus
dans cette émission et l'assemblée se
penche sur une proposition de résolution
transpartisanes visant à demander au
gouvernement de marquer son refus quant
à la signature de l'accord entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur tel qu'il a
été conclu en 2019 Marco pommier vous
êtes avec Dominique potier qui est
député socialiste et qui est
consignataire de cette proposition de
résolution oui Brigitte Dominique petit
on va revenir sur votre proposition de
résolution mais d'abord pour ceux qui
nous écoutent pour bien comprendre en
quoi consiste cet accord entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur c'est un
traité de libre-échange qui vise à
amplifier les échanges commerciaux entre
l'Union européenne et nations de l'Union
européenne sont l'économie et celle des
pays d'Amérique du Sud
très bien votre proposition de
résolution elle se veut transpartisane
elle vise à demander au gouvernement de
refuser la signature de cet accord
pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous craignez
parce que c'est un accord totalement
archaïque qui ne tient pas compte des
défis du monde contemporain celui
notamment de la sécurité alimentaire
celui de la question sanitaire et
d'alimentation il tient pas compte
également des questions du climat on
fait comme s'il n'y avait pas eu la COP
21 comme si elle avait pas la forêt
amazonienne qui crame que vous avez pas
eu la forêt boréale comme si on n'avait
pas nous-mêmes des problèmes autour du
terriblement climatique c'est un accord
surtout qui ne tient pas compte du défi
démographique nous aurons à nourrir
ensemble 10 milliards d'habitants en
2050 et toutes les études je pense à
athera Monda et d'autres disent que pour
nourrir le monde nous aurons besoin de
tous les paysans et de toutes les terres
du monde or c'est exactement le
contraire qu'on fait avec cet accord
puisque le bœuf Brésilien ou le poulet
brésilien va détruire l'économie
agricole de notre pays aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus signer d'accord qui détruisent
des terres qui détruisent l'Amazonie et
qui détruisent les pays parce qu'on aura
besoin de tout le monde pour nourrir le
monde c'est surtout un accord qui va
amplifier le dérèglement climatique et
ça c'est un écosside alors vous n'êtes
pas opposé quand même aux principes d'un
accord de libre-échange mais vous le
voulez donc on l'a compris le
conditionner c'est ça à des à
l'accord de Paris par exemple à des
causes et à des clauses exactement mais
très franchement est-ce qu'un accord de
libre-échange est-ce que ça peut être
vertueux la France insoumise dit par
exemple que c'est impossible moi je
pense que les accords de libre-échange
par principe sont totalement dépassés il
nous faut inventer un mode souveraineté
solidaire des coopérations nouvelles il
ne faut SURTOUT inventer une des traités
de juste échange le libre-échange c'est
totalement dépassé nous devons avoir une
boussole la boussole c'est le respect
des droits humains la dignité du travail
agricole ici et dans les pays d'Amérique
du Sud et c'est notre capacité encore
une on peut le mesurer tout ça à travers
un accord de libre-échange on peut le
faire à travers un accord de juste
échange avec une boussole qui est le
climat les droits humains et la sécurité
alimentaire encore une fois c'est le
premier rouge qui ne sont pas respectés
comment imaginer en 2023 engagé des
négociations qui amplifient la
déforestation de l'Amazonie et qui
fragilise les 5 millions d'hectares de
de toutes de toute du cœur de la France
du Massif central qui tiennent autour
d'une économie de l'élevage bovin c'est
totalement insensé et nos combattons
mais fermement cet accord donc
combattons également les termes dans
lesquels il est débattu il y a une
séparation entre l'accord commercial et
le traité global il y a une opacité
totale sur les négociations elle nous
refaisons nous parlementaires nous
société civiles organisées je pense aux
syndicalisme agricole je pense aux ONG
environnementales d'être spectateurs
d'un accord qui serait dans des box
opaque ça c'est totalement dépassé on
doit discuter en transparence et on doit
avoir une boussole merci beaucoup
Dominique petit on le rappelle votre
proposition de résolution elle va être
examinée tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
ce sera juste après les questions au
Gouvernement
si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à 25 minutes des
questions au Gouvernement vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur LCP toujours ici au
coeur de l'Assemblée nationale dans
cette belle salle des pas perdus où vous
verrez tout à l'heure derrière moi
s'installer la Garde Républicaine elle
jouera du tambour à l'arrivée de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale ce
sera aux alentours de 15h alors voici
notre dispositif pour cette deuxième
partie d'émission vous retrouverez elles
à mon un Gava et Marco pommier qui se
trouve salle des quatre colonnes et vous
retrouverez également Clément mairie qui
lui est déjà dans les tribunes de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
vous verrez également à partir de 14h45
l'arrivée de la première ministre de
tous les membres du gouvernement ce sera
par l'entrée principale du palais
Bourbon la cour d'honneur alors que vous
entendez déjà derrière moi la garde
républicaine qui prend position dans
cette salle des pas perdus Clément
mairie qu'on vous retrouve dans les
tribunes de l'hémicycle les députés ne
sont pas encore là mais vous vous avez
pris connaissance du menu des questions
au gouvernement alors quel est le thème
principal
qui sera abordé cet après-midi
le thème principal Brigitte ce sera
cette attaque au couteau d'Annecy de la
semaine dernière qui va faire l'objet de
trois questions posées par trois des
quatre députés de Haute-Savoie tous
membres de la majorité question à la
fois sur le déroulé des événements mais
aussi sur les modalités d'intervention
des forces de l'ordre et des secours à
noter que le profil de l'auteur de cette
attaque un réfugié syrien dans la
demande d'asile venait d'être rejeté par
la France son profil sera évoqué par le
député RN Yohann Gillet dans sa question
sur le projet de loi immigration de quoi
parlerons-nous également dans cette
séance et bien tout d'abord de la
problématique des déserts médicaux alors
que l'assemblée examine en ce moment la
proposition de loi valthou et notamment
cet amendement cosigné par 200 députés
de tous les groupes politiques pour
imposer des contraintes à l'installation
des médecins libéraux il y aura deux
questions posées sur ce sujet par les
groupes communistes et l'iott les
groupes Renaissance et les républicains
eux comptent interpellé le gouvernement
sur la dernière action en date du
collectif les soulèvements de la terre
qui a visé une exploitation agricole ce
weekend en loire-at donc exploitation
agricole accusée de s'accaparer l'eau
enfin le groupe LFI compte interroger le
gouvernement sur les perquisitions qui
ont été menées ce matin dans le 4 dans
le cadre de l'enquête sur l'attribution
des fonds Mariannes merci Clément Méric
pour ce menu complet des questions au
Gouvernement j'accueille à présent sur
ce plateau pour cette deuxième partie
des missions Céline Calvez bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes députés
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine et Kevin
mauvieux bonjour vous êtes député
rassemblement national de l'Eure alors
la question des déserts médicaux va
s'inviter vous avez entendu Clément
Méric dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale cet après-midi alors que la
proposition de loi de Frédéric valthou
du groupe horizon et débattu depuis hier
elle vise à lutter contre les déserts
médicaux il y aura une question du
groupe GDR communiste Nicolas sans Sud
député du Cher va interpeller le
gouvernement et il est à votre micro
elle a mon Agava qu'allez-vous proposer
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
qui allez vous demander on va demander
une forme de régulation pour permettre
au médecin au médecin qui s'installe de
d'aller où ils veulent dans les zones
d'itsu dotés c'est-à-dire les
territoires qui en manquent et faire en
sorte que seuls les médecins qui
remplacent un départ en retraite où
quelqu'un qui est parti d'une zone
surdité puisse installer dans ces zones
là tout simplement pour permettre qu'il
y ait un peu plus d'égalité territoriale
vous voulez une régulation de la
coercition même sur les médecins qui
voudraient aller dans les zones où il y
en a déjà beaucoup on parle de
coercition on nous dit qu'il y a 87% du
territoire qui serait concernés par les
déserts médicaux donc c'est possible
coercition sur 13%, je pense que ce
n'est pas vraiment une coercition au
contraire je pense que c'est aussi une
question de République parce que
aujourd'hui l'égalité territoriale n'est
plus du tout assurée et on est dans une
situation où nos concitoyens ne
comprennent pas qu'il y ait des médecins
et qui puissent s'installer n'importe où
sans règles alors que on voit que les
pharmaciens ont des obligations on voit
que les infirmiers ont des obligations
et c'est normal que ce soit quelque
chose qui soit non pas du service public
mais du service au public votre question
elle tombe à pic il y a une proposition
de loi débattues vous pensez que
l'amendement qui est porté par le groupe
transpartisan pour demander plus de
régulation pour être adopté oui c'est
l'objectif que l'on s'est fixé puisque
je fais partie des 42 au départ de ce de
cette proposition de loi transpartisane
je crois sincèrement que si c'était
adopté ce serait un bon signe pour
l'avenir ça réglerait peut-être pas tout
mais au moins la bataille culturelle
serait en phase d'être gagnée
merci beaucoup Nicolas ascension on
écoutera votre question dans l'hémicycle
et puis on suit évidemment la
proposition de loi qui reviendra après
alors Céline qu'elle vas il y a
effectivement cet amendement
transpartisan porté par le député
socialiste Guillaume Garraud qui vise à
réguler l'installation des médecins voir
à les contraintes de s'installer dans
des zones qui sont sous dotées est-ce
que la majorité
pourraient ou en tout cas certains
députés pourraient voter cet amendement
je pense qu'il y a certains des députés
qui ont fait partie de ce groupe de
travail transpartisans donc ils ont pu
évoluer aussi sur cette question là je
pense qu'on a tous à coeur surtout de
définir c'est quoi un désert médical et
moi qui suis dans les Hauts-de-Seine on
pourrait croire qu'il y a pas de désert
médical si il y en a c'est pas forcément
dans les zones rurales c'est pas
forcément uniquement dans ces zones là
maintenant la question c'est par rapport
à l'installation de notre médecin je
voudrais rappeler déjà en premier lieu
qu'on est en pénurie de médecin et que
même si on a pu changer le numéro de
clausus qu'ils faisaient qu'on avait
quelque chose qui n'avait pas changé
depuis 1970 ça ne fait pas tout de suite
ses effets on va avoir des départs
massifs en retraite et donc on va avoir
devant nous encore plus cette question
des arts médicales ce qu'il faut
regarder c'est quelle est la différence
entre l'obligation d'installation et la
limitation d'installation l'obligation
d'installation ce serait de dire à un
professionnel de santé tu n'as aucune
aucune aucun aucune et on te dit un peu
comme mon frère avec des fonctionnaires
et c'est pas du tout le cas de dire il
faut que tu t'installes là la limitation
de l'installation c'est peut-être déjà
d'éclairer qu'est-ce qui est un
territoire qui serait sous doté surdoté
je crois qu'aujourd'hui en France on
peut pas dire qu'il est territoire qui
soit surdotés par contre de pouvoir
donner des informations supplémentaires
que ce soit au médecin mais aussi aux
patients en disant voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui c'est important et c'est pas
qu'une question de nombre de médecins
c'est pas qu'une question de nombre
aussi de population faut regarder aussi
le temps de travail des médecins
aujourd'hui on a des médecins qui ne
souhaitent pas travailler 7 jours sur 7
et on peut les comprendre donc il y a
pas seulement cette question de nombres
mais il y a peut-être aussi cette
incitation mais c'est aussi cet
éclairage de la de limiter l'assure
installation pour revenir sur cette
amendement c'est pas tout à fait une
contrainte mais c'est de dire voilà
quand il y a un médecin qui part à la
retraite ou qui déménage et bien il y a
la possibilité de s'installer mais sinon
on ne peut pas s'installer et tout ça
avec l'accord de l'ARS est-ce que ça ça
vous paraît acceptable ou est-ce que
pour vous ça va créer justement cette
pénurie de médecin mais en fait ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'elles vont être les
relations entre les jeunes médecins et
les médecins à la retraite et ce qui va
pas y avoir un phénomène de pression
pour que des médecins qui pourraient
partir à la retraite partent en retraite
la question c'est la question du choix
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de cumul
emploi retraite parmi les médecins
certains c'est parce que ils ont besoin
d'avoir plus de moyens certains aussi se
disent mais il y a personne qui va me
remplacer donc il faut que je fasse ce
cumul emploi retraite il ne faudrait pas
que cette que cette demande de
remplacement d'un ancien par un jeune
devienne une éviction des anciens alors
que même là on est encore en
sous-effectif de professionnels
évidemment Kevin ma vieux il y a cet
amendement transpartisan mais le
rassemblement national n'y a pas été
associé quel est votre position à vous
sur cet amendement qui vise à réguler
l'installation médecin déjà je voudrais
juste revenir sur ce que vous venez
d'indiquer c'est à dire que c'est pas un
amendement transpartisan un amendement
transpartisan par définition et la
vocation a touché tous les partis c'est
un amendement on va dire de macronie
élargie la France insoumise à appeler à
voter Macron tous les groupes du
rassemblement national voilà donc en
réalité c'est la macronie contre
l'opposition maintenant
nous au niveau de cet amendement on a un
problème c'est à dire que ce qu'on
identifie à travers cette amendement
c'est que s'il était voté et appliqué
nous ce qu'on craint c'est une crise
d'évocation c'est à dire que la médecine
aujourd'hui c'est un métier libéral et
si vous commencez à fonctionnariser
entre guillemets ce métier en imposant
au jeune médecin qui sortent de l'école
à quel endroit ils doivent se
s'installer il y a une certaine entrave
aux côtés libéral du métier et on a peur
à une crise d'évocation on a déjà de
grosses difficultés à avoir des médecins
parce qu'on a été bloqué par le numerus
clausus pendant suffisamment longtemps
d'ailleurs qui est le sans être levé on
a quand même toujours des contraintes à
ce niveau là notamment au niveau des
académies et des possibilités de
formation donc on a toujours ce goulet
d'étranglement si en plus de se gauler
d'étranglement on ajoute une espèce
d'entonnoir à la base en disant vous
pourrez être médecin mais vous n'irez
pas où vous voulez on va assister à une
crise d'évocation nous rassemblement
national on est plus partisans de
l'incitation et de la modulation
l'incitation c'est l'incitation fiscale
il faut que le médecin qui va
s'installer dans un désert médical et un
avantage à le faire contrairement à
celui qui irait dans une zone qui serait
normalement dotée parce que je ne pense
effectivement pas à quelques rares
exceptions qui est de zone surdotée ça
je vous rejoins là dessus et puis la
modulation c'est à dire que on pourrait
imaginer un système ou par exemple le
montant de la consultation serait plus
élevé plus important dans une zone sous
dotée que dans une zone normalement
dotée pour inciter encore une fois la
modulation en tout cas sur cet
amendement pour le rejeter est-ce que
vous allez voter la proposition de loi
de Frédéric Valtou je ne sais pas encore
j'attends de voir comment les débats
vont se se dérouler dans l'hémicycle
c'est voilà c'est à peu près
et ils vont se poursuivre on va passer à
présent à une question citoyenne parce
que vous savez sur LCP on demande aux
citoyens quelle question ils auraient
poser s'ils étaient dans l'hémicycle à
la place des des députés cet après-midi
alors je vous propose d'entendre Richard
qui est architecte et qui a une question
pour le ministre du Logement
Richard Guillemot architecte en centre
Bretagne monsieur le ministre du
Logement j'aimerais vous interpeller sur
un phénomène qui touche la construction
du logement social
qui est la dévalorisation de
l'utilisation des matériaux biosourcés
j'aimerais si c'est possible vous
interrogez sur ce sujet et vous pousser
à valoriser l'utilisation par exemple de
l'ossature bois des bardages bois de
tous les matériaux qui stockent du
carbone merci
alors la question de Richard c'est
est-ce qu'il faut encourager finalement
la filière bois des incitations pour le
bois pour éviter de construire avec trop
de carbone mais je pense qu'il faut
encourager cette filière parce qu'on l'a
vu en plus on a vraiment des expertises
là dessus en France que ça soit depuis
la construction de Notre-Dame on s'est
posé beaucoup de questions sur la façon
dont avait été créé cette charpente mais
aujourd'hui vous envoyez de plus en plus
et en fait ça contribue à toute cette
filière que ça soit les métiers voilà ou
que ça soit la provenance donc je pense
qu'on peut l'encourager après il y a
bien sûr dans le logement social et dans
tous les logements à prendre en compte
le caractère durable mais aussi le
caractère finançable de tout ce que
notre pays a besoin en termes de
logement il faudrait peut-être des
incitations dans le prochain budget pour
favoriser cette filière bois pourquoi
pas nous on a rien contre cette filière
à condition que ce soit une filière
éco-responsable jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire que le bois vient de France
soit transformé en France et soit et
soit utilisé en France qu'on n'aille pas
couper des arbres français pour les
envoyer en Chine pour les transformer
pour les ramener en France sinon ça perd
totalement de sa finalité mais ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que dans le PIB
français on a quand même 11% du PIB
français qui est du domaine de la
construction du domaine du logement on a
énormément de logements sociaux parce
qu'on a une loi SRU plutôt pas trop mal
faite qui fait ensemble de données un
accès à 25 % de la population dans les
villes à ce type de logement et depuis 6
ans maintenant on a une crise du
logement pourquoi parce que les
financements et notamment les
financements en vert les bailleurs
sociaux sont à l'arrêt on freine tout ce
qui est le secteur de l'habitation en
termes d'investissement et ça c'est le
bilan d'Emmanuel Macron sur le principe
ça fait 6 ans qu'il est là ça fait 6 ans
que les bailleurs sociaux voient des
coupes de robinet et aujourd'hui il s'en
plaignent et ils le disent très
clairement quand vous les interrogez
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont de moins en moins
de ressources de moins en moins de
financement et qu'on a une crise du
logement
mais effectivement elle aura lieu sur
les financements et ce sera plutôt à
l'automne on va revenir maintenant à une
question au gouvernement en revenant sur
ce drame qui s'est produit à Annecy la
semaine dernière un une attaque au
couteau qui a fait ciblesser dont quatre
enfants très jeunes autour de trois ans
et c'est le député de la circonscription
Antoine Armand qui va interpeller le
gouvernement il pose d'abord sa question
au micro de Marco pommier oui Brigitte
Antoine Armand l'attaque au couteau
s'est produite dans votre
circonscription et vous avez assisté
dimanche dernier au rassemblement sur
les lieux du drame à Annecy
qu'allez-vous dire aujourd'hui au
gouvernement et la représentation
nationale je vais dire d'abord toute la
pensée des années siennes et des années
siens pour leur victime les victimes
françaises mais des victimes européennes
aussi le faire devant la représentation
nationale et je vais aussi exprimer la
reconnaissance de toute la
représentation nationale à l'égard de
ces héros qui ont évité le pire tout
simplement
certains ont accusé la droite et le
rassemblement national d'avoir utilisé
le drame d'Annecy pour prendre position
sur le thème de l'immigration vous aussi
vous avez pris position et vous appelez
à revenir notamment sur les règles de
circulation dans l'espace Schengen
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne pas pour vous
non ce que ce que j'appelle c'est à
ouvrir le débat en toute sérénité il
faut d'un côté dénoncer la récupération
politique sordide d'un autre côté il
faut aussi ne pas avoir de fausse pudeur
il faut regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont nous avons impact asile
immigration qui a été adopté par le
Conseil européen qui va être examiné par
le Parlement s'il y a des questions qui
se posent et si l'enquête qui est menée
mène à un certain nombre de réflexions
et de propositions nous devrons les
saisir c'est notre responsabilité merci
beaucoup Anton Armand et on écoutera
votre question au gouvernement tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle Céline Calvese
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles des
victimes est-ce que vous savez comment
vont les enfants aujourd'hui pas
forcément à ce jour précisément mais on
y prête forcément attention et on prête
surtout un message d'espoir pour les
habitants d'Annecy et puis pour tous les
Français face à cela il faut pas
utiliser instrumentaliser ce qui a été
fait mais plutôt veiller à ce que c'est
en sorte les victimes de ce qui s'est
passé à Annecy la semaine dernière
est-ce qu'on peut améliorer la prise en
charge des victimes Kevin mauvieux
est-ce que l'État a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait faire vous saluer par exemple le
déplacement l'intervention de du
président de la République le
déplacement de la première ministre
immédiatement du ministre de l'Intérieur
moi ce que je salue c'est surtout
l'intervention de secours qui a sauvé
les victimes des secours des soignants
des aides-soignants qui encore
aujourd'hui
s'occupent des victimes au quotidien
pour essayer que que les personnes s'en
sortent après saluer le déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron et d'Elizabeth borne
je pense que c'est pas très utile dans
la mesure où ils n'ont sauvé personne et
que en réalité c'est plus leur politique
et la continuité de leur politique qui
fait que cette personne a pu être sur
notre territoire de cette façon là alors
j'entends bien de partout qu'on nous
reproche d'utiliser ce thème et d'en
parler mais enfin désolé mais si on nous
le reproche aussi souvent c'est bien que
le problème n'est pas réglé ni par la
droite ni par la gauche ni par la
macronie donc n'est pas arrivé un petit
peu vite après le drame d'Annecy bah moi
la polémique si vous voulez vous
reprenez mon intervention à titre
personnel je suis intervenu une heure
après sur une chaîne concurrente j'ai
bien dit qu'il fallait pas faire
polémique que le temps était à la prise
en charge des victimes à la réflexion et
qu'il fallait attendre des éléments
après à partir du moment où les éléments
arrivent sur la table qu'on sait que
cette personne est une personne
immigrée qui a un droit d'asile en Suède
mais pas en France qui s'est même vu
refusé en France quand tous ces éléments
arrivent il est normal qu'on en discute
alors après je sais bien qu'on a des
personnes qui sont douées d'une moralité
plus vertueuse que celle des autres et
qui savent à partir de combien d'heures
on a le droit de parler d'un sujet mais
malheureusement il y a urgence c'est
arrivé ça peut se reproduire il y a
urgence vous vous dites qu'il n'y a pas
eu une polémique immédiate en tout cas
de votre part mais c'est vrai que cette
polémique elle est quand même très vite
montée après le drame d'Annecy elle est
venue de l'extrême droite et de la
droite c'est Johan Gillet qui est député
rassemblement national du Gard qui
compte interpeller le gouvernement sur
cette question cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle de la semaine nationale et
il pose sa question d'abord au micro
d'Elsa monava oui vous allez demander un
calendrier sur le projet de loi
immigration et des précisions oui bien
sûr écouter ce projet de loi immigration
on l'attend depuis tellement longtemps
qu'on se demande s'il va finir par
arriver en l'occurrence les Français
attendent ce projet immigration avec
impatience parce qu'il y a des gros
problèmes liés à l'immigration on le
sait d'ailleurs cette Français sur 10
réclame des mesures plus strictes en
matière d'immigration donc il est temps
que Gérald Darmanin se bouge et
travaille enfin agissent c'est ce qu'on
attend c'est ce que les Français
attendent vous n'allez pas citer
directement le drame dancing mais ce que
vous allez demander de réviser le droit
d'asile par exemple est-ce que c'est
aussi l'occasion pour vous de parler de
ce sujet d'immigration bien sûr mais je
vais dire à Gérald Darmanin tout
simplement et bien qu'il y a un projet
qui est prêt clé en main pour lutter
contre l'immigration massive ce projet
c'est le projet de Marine Le Pen elle
l'a exposé il les clés en main Gérald
Darmanin pourrait très bien faire de ce
projet le sien et nous le soutiendrons
dans ce cas là plutôt que de laisser
penser et laisser croire qu'il va sortir
quelque chose alors que ça fait des mois
qui promet un texte de fermeté en
l'occurrence le pré projet qui était
sorti il y a quelques mois était tout
sauf ferme c'était au contraire comment
régulariser massivement les clandestins
ce dont les Français ne veulent pas donc
je vais lui dire qu'il faut agir et que
les Français attendent enfin du concret
écoutez le ministre de l'Intérieur
donnera peut-être des précisions de
calendrier effectivement pas forcément
en tête présente en juillet mais à
l'automne Céline calvaise est-ce que le
projet de loi immigration qui n'est qui
est encore en discussion parce que vous
vous rapprochez peut-être de la droite
sur cette question là est-ce que ce
projet de loi immigration il pourrait
répondre à une question comme le drame
d'Annecy c'est-à-dire ce problème du
droit d'asile où on a vu un Syrien qui
s'est vu refuser la nationalité suédoise
mais qui a demandé l'asile en France il
l'avait on lui avait refusé quatre jours
auparavant ça peut peut-être expliquer
ce geste je pense qu'il faut pas pas
forcément lié le drame d'Annecy à la
problématique de l'immigration par
contre effectivement il y a cette ce
projet de loi immigration qui doit
répondre aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
et en fait contrairement à ce que
l'invité précédent disait en fait le
projet qu'on avait présenté déjà avec
Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du soft il
était équilibré pourquoi parce qu'on ne
faisait quelque chose que la droite
n'avait jamais fait donc n'était pas
allé jusqu'au bout et que la gauche
n'avait jamais fait deux choses d'un
côté c'est d'être beaucoup plus ferme
sur les flux irréguliers c'est la
maîtrise de flux et ça on est prêt à
aller loin mais de l'autre côté
effectivement de pouvoir régulariser des
personnes qui sont sur notre territoire
et qui puissent comme ça répondre aux
métiers en tension ça l'est aussi c'est
même encore plus loin donc en fait on a
vraiment besoin de ces deux choses
l'idée et pour notre groupe c'est
vraiment d'être aussi bien ferme sur la
maîtrise des flux irréguliers mais aussi
plus humaniste sur l'accueil de la
maîtrise des flux effectivement pour les
personnes qui arrivent illégalement sur
les territoires on vous entend pas trop
parler des personnes qui ne doivent pas
rester sur le territoire celle pour qui
il faut des ce qu'on appelle des occupe
une obligation de quitter le territoire
français pour nous c'est vraiment le le
ce qui est irrégulier ce qui doit être
96 % selon un Cours des comptes à ne pas
quitter le territoire français une fois
qu'ils y sont arrivés illégalement c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup des
eaux-couturières on les compare souvent
à l'Allemagne mais nous en fait on
délire les hôpitaux beaucoup plus en
amont quand l'Allemagne il se les
personnes est déjà dans l'avion quand il
le délivre donc en fait on vous va
pouvoir comparer ce qui est comparable
en fait c'est pour ça nous on veut aller
plus loin sur la fermeté de tout ce qui
doit être respecté mais on doit aussi
ouvrir la possibilité à ce que on
intègre des personnes qui vont être
utiles en plus un être économie une
autre société on ne peut pas parler
d'immigration sans parler d'intégration
et on a besoin d'avoir ces deux pieds là
et pas qu'un seul Kevin ma vieux
immigration et intégration ce sont les
deux piliers de ce projet de loi est-ce
qu'il vous convient ce sont les deux
piliers nécessaires mais ce ne sont pas
les deux piliers du projet
immigration et l'intégration vous avez
une immigration qu'elle soit contrôlée
ou non choisie ou non et que vous
l'intégrez pas ça se passera mal ça
c'est obligatoire c'est incontournable
et d'ailleurs c'est
donc vous n'êtes pas vraiment sur le
volet intégration
c'est là où je voulais réagir ce que
j'entends est quand même relativement
lunaire d'abord ma collègue dit qu'il ne
faut pas relier ce qui s'est passé à
Annecy à l'immigration bah pardon c'est
un migrant on l'invente pas on le sent
pas du chapeau c'est un migrant donc on
ne relie rien on constate ensuite il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui sont des
migrants et qui ne posent aucun problème
aussi sur le territoire mais forcé de
constater que c'est un migrant donc il
vient de la migration ensuite à côté de
ça j'entends quelque chose aussi qui me
fait sourire c'est à dire que on va être
faire on va être plus ferme vis-à-vis de
l'immigration et en même temps on va
envoyer le signal aux migrants s'ils
viennent travailler en France on leur
donnera leurs papiers donc là pareil on
danse sur deux pieds c'est en même temps
qu'il ne peut pas marcher donc soit on
sera très ferme et on ne donnera pas les
titres à ceux qui travaillent réellement
soit on donnera les titres réellement et
on ne sera pas ferme et moi je vous le
dis où est-ce que ça va finir ça va
finir de la même façon que ça se passe
depuis des décennies ça va se finir à
une régularisation massive un appel
d'air on va rester avec à peine 10% de
qtf réalisé et enfin un dernier élément
quand on parlait des auqf qui m'a fait
sourire dans les propos de ma collègue
c'est que l'argument c'est dire en
Allemagne le taux de réussite est mieux
parce qu'il donne les auqf aux gens qui
sont dans les avions enfin qu'on donne
les aucutaient aux gens qui sont déjà
dans les avions ou qu'on mette les gens
qui ont des aucutés dans des avions dans
les deux cas le résultat final il y a
une solution miracle vous pour
accompagner ces gens-là la première
solution avant d'avoir aller
raccompagner c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils ne viennent pas comment ça se
passe il faut que les demandes d'asile
que les demandes de papier de
nationalité française soit réalisée dans
les consulats français à l'étranger il
faut arrêter de dire venez ici demander
et qu'on vous dise oui ou non vous
resterez il faut arrêter avec ce système
qui marche sur la tête et le système des
hotspot c'est à dire aux frontières des
des pays
frontières frontières de l'Europe est-ce
que ça c'est quand même déjà une
solution pour éviter qu'ils arrivent
directement sur le territoire français
ou que ce soit une solution parce que
encore une fois on les laisse venir à la
frontière pour demander leur papier donc
à partir du moment où il franchissent la
frontière et où ils demandent ils sont
sur le territoire et vous pouvez leur
donner des auqtf vous pouvez leur dire
de chez eux on le voit aujourd'hui ça ne
changera pas il ne rentreront pas chez
eux c'est c'est un fait c'est comme ça
on est obligé de c'est un constat voilà
c'est il y a pas d'extrémisme là-dedans
c'est un constat donc la bataille elle
aura lieu à l'automne sur ce projet de
loot à l'automne suivons un peu ce qui
se passe aussi au niveau européen avec
le pacte immigration ne pourra pas faire
sans l'Europe et donc ça il faudra
vraiment se garder et puis pourquoi pas
une convention citoyenne sur
l'immigration et sur l'intégration ce
serait intéressant aussi pour concerner
l'ensemble des Français à cette
problématique et de ne pas tomber dans
le on va dire politicien merci Céline
Calvez d'avoir été avec nous merci Kevin
nos yeux d'être venu débat sur le
plateau de question d'actualité les
questions au Gouvernement c'est dans
moins de 3 minutes maintenant Marco poly
on va vous retrouver vous vous êtes
salle des quatre colonnes pour les
principales questions qui seront posées
cet après-midi dans les mythiques de
l'Assemblée oui brigitte a un sujet va
s'imposer dans l'hémicycle l'attaque au
couteau d'Annecy attaque qui je vous le
rappelle a fait si blesser donc quatre
enfants et qui a suscité beaucoup
d'émotions mais aussi
prise de position politique sur le thème
de l'immigration alors que la saillant
était un réfugié syrien des questions
aussi cet après-midi sur les déserts
médicaux on parlera aussi de la dernière
action polémique du collectif les
soulèvements de la terre sans oublier à
l'école quid de la mixité sociale dans
les établissements scolaires tout un
programme végétal merci Marco pommier
effectivement un programme encore chargé
pour cette séance de questions au
gouvernement on va retrouver les Amanda
qui est également celle des quatre
colonnes on est à moins de 2 minutes
maintenant de ces questions quelle est
l'ambiance de votre côté bien écoutez
ambiance longuement de motion de censure
pas mal de députés pas mal de
journalistes je réexplique pour noter
les spectateurs la salle des quatre
colonnes c'est ici que les journalistes
peuvent interroger les députés juste
avant qu'il rentre dans l'hémicycle
alors évidemment si les députés passent
c'est pour être en partie interviewée
regardez là il y a Pierre Alexandre
glace du groupe Renaissance qui répond à
quelques questions et puis ensuite et
bien il file tous dans l'hémicycle et
nous on reste dans cette salle pour
suivre la séance des questions au
Gouvernement évidemment
merci Elsa moninga va 14h50 9 et les
tambours de la Garde Républicaine sont
déjà en train de retentir pour
accueillir la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui va traverser cette salle
des pas perdue dans quelques instants
beaucoup beaucoup de monde ici Salle des
pas perdue à l'inverse de la salle des
quatre colonnes parce que vous le savez
il est de plus en plus facile maintenant
de visiter l'Assemblée nationale on peut
s'inscrire sur le site internet et donc
il y a beaucoup de Français qui sont
curieux de voir ce cérémonial que vous
découvrez actuellement à l'antenne
[Musique]